اجتمع قادة من دولة الإمارات قطر والبحرين وسلطنة عمان
والأردن ومصر هنا
اليوم في أبو ظبي ، حيث التقى القادة
لمناقشة التعاون الأمني ​​السياسي والاقتصادي.
أبو ظبي
تتجمع بشكل جيد يأتي هذا بعد يوم من
احتفال الإمارات العربية المتحدة بسنواتها منذ أن
قتل
ثلاثة أشخاص في أبو ظبي في
أعقاب الهجوم الصاروخي وطائرة بدون طيار ،
أخبرني سفير الإمارات لدى الأمم المتحدة لانا نسيبي
أن الإمارات تحتفظ بالحق في  تدافع عن
نفسها ،
استمع ، ستستمر في السيادة وفي
نفس الوقت نحتفظ بالحق في
الدفاع عن أنفسنا وسيمارس هذا
الحق بطريقة تتفق
مع القانون الدولي وسيكون
متناسبًا ويلتزم بالقانون الدولي
الإنساني ولكن على  في الوقت نفسه ،
نحتفظ بالحق الكامل في الدفاع عن
أمن وسلامة ملايين
الأشخاص من مختلف الدول  es
حول العالم الذين اختاروا السفر
إلى الإمارات العربية المتحدة واختاروا استدعاء الإمارات
وطنهم 32000 وما يزيد عن اثنين وثلاثين
ألف شخص بالعبور عبر
مطار أبو ظبي كل يوم
وكان ذلك أحد الأهداف كما
نعرف الآن أه من  هجوم 17 يناير
الذي كان لورين قاله من خلال حديثه
معي هذا الوقت من العام الماضي ،
أصدر البيت الأبيض بيانًا من
الرئيس جو بايدن يوم الثلاثاء قال فيه
قبل عام واحد في هجوم إرهابي
انطلق من اليمن على
صواريخ باليستية في سلسلة من الطائرات بدون طيار التي استهدفت.
المواقع المدنية في دولة الإمارات العربية
المتحدة اليوم نتذكر الأرواح
التي فقدت بشكل مأساوي
وأكدنا مجددًا التزام الولايات المتحدة
بسلامة
وأمن الشعب الإماراتي.
حسنًا ، ضيفي التالي هو عبد الخالق
عبد الله ، أستاذ العلوم السياسية الإماراتي
أم أريد.  للحديث عن
الذكرى كما كانت أو بعد مرور عام
على أه الهجوم على الإمارات من قبل
طائرات مسيرة مسلحة تابعة للحوثيين مؤقتًا
لأنها
ذكرى سنوية مهمة ويذكرها البيت الأبيض
هذا العام
ويقرها والتي تختلف تمامًا
عن استجابتها أو عدم الاستجابة في هذا
الوقت من العام الماضي والتي
أغضبت الإمارات قبل أن أفعل ذلك ، دعونا
نتحدث فقط عن الاجتماع الذي كان
هنا.
في وقت سابق تلاوة الاجتماع التي
تشير إلى أن القادة يقصدون مناقشة
التعاون السياسي والاقتصادي والأمني ​​، أريدك
أن تتعمق لأن هذا بيان Anodyne للغاية
قراءة وتنقيب
لنا إذا كنت تريد ما
هي أولويات هذه
البلدان ودعونا نذكر أنفسنا  على وجه
التحديد الإمارات العربية المتحدة وقطر معًا اليوم هنا
في أبو ظبي مؤخرًا فقط بعد
الحديث عن المصطلحات بالطبع ،
ما رأيك في ما رأيناه
جيدًا شكرًا لاستضافتي بيكي مرة أخرى
هنا واه
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، لقد كنت بالفعل على وجه
الخصوص أقل من  استقبال كبار الشخصيات
والقادة العالميين والقادة الإقليميين
للعام الماضي وخاصة في الآونة الأخيرة ،
ويأتي ذلك استمرارًا لتوصية أبوظبي
أعطي قادة المنطقة هذا الاجتماع
ولكن بطريقة يمكنني قراءته
كإظهار للتضامن مع الإمارات العربية المتحدة التي
تمر كما قلت بشكل صحيح في
الذكرى السنوية الأولى للهجوم ولكن
هناك الكثير للحديث عنه عندما
يكون لديك مثل هذا التجمع وأنا  فكر
على رأس هذه القضايا
المهمة والتي تهمنا جميعًا ،
كيف نعيد نوعًا من
الاستقرار إلى منطقة فقدت
استقرارها في أعقاب الربيع العربي.
القادة
بطريقة تظهر تضامنهم ولكنهم
يناقشون أيضًا الاستقرار
الإقليمي الاستقرار الإقليمي الذي سيشمل
بالطبع
أم إسرائيل والقضية الفلسطينية ويأتي
هذا
الاجتماع في أعقاب اجتماعهم
لقادة مصر والأردن على
وجه التحديد مع أم الفلسطينيين في
مصر
أم.  مؤخرًا
عندما تنظر إلى الصورة
التي أظهرناها لأولئك الذين التقوا في أبو ظبي
اليوم ،
ما التالي
بالنسبة للفلسطينيين وكيف كان التأثير
على الأرض على  شوارع
الدعم للفلسطينيين في جميع أنحاء هذه
المنطقة تعني بالنسبة لأولئك
القادة المجتمعين
، أعتقد أن الفلسطينيين ربما
يواجهون واحدة من أصعب اللحظات في
نضالهم بسبب هذه
الحكومة اليمينية للغاية التي يجب
علينا التعامل معها مع نتنياهو
وشركته  لذا أعتقد أن هناك
رسالة هنا تخرج من هذا
الاجتماع للفلسطينيين أننا لا ندير
ظهرنا أه للقضايا الفلسطينية
يجب أن نكون هناك من أجلهم
وأعتقد أن القضية الفلسطينية ربما كانت من
بين أهم
القضايا التي تمت مناقشتها  وكيفية
التعامل مع هذه الحكومة الجديدة في إسرائيل
هي على الأرجح قضية أخرى هناك
سيكون الأمر محرجًا للغاية
مع العلاقة الطبيعية الطبيعية عندما
يكون لديك أشخاص مثل بنغافور من بين
آخرين ممن هم مجرد
توسعيين يريدون ضم كل الضفة الغربية لذلك أنا
أعتقد أنه عندما يلتقي هؤلاء القادة
، أعتقد أن هذا النوع
من المواقف المشتركة حول كيفية تعاملنا
مع هذه الحكومة هو بالتأكيد  في إسرائيل ،
ربما تمت مناقشة هذا الأمر بالتفصيل في
غياب المملكة العربية
السعودية ، ويتوقع المرء أن يكون ولي
العهد محمد بن سلمان
يمثل
أم تلك الدولة ، ما رأيك في
غيابه عن تلك المجموعة
التي لن تجعلها  جزء كبير
منه أعتقد أن من صنعه أه
هو الذي يتم الترحيب به
والذين غابوا لديهم أسبابهم الخاصة
لعدم القيام بذلك أعتقد أن المملكة العربية السعودية
اليوم منخرطة في
قضيتها الداخلية الداخلية.  مشغول
كثيرًا برؤية 2030 ، لكنني أعتقد أنهم
يعرفون تمامًا ما يدور حوله هذا الاجتماع
وسيتم إطلاعهم بشكل كامل
في الوقت المناسب ، لذلك أنا حقًا لا أشعر
بأي شيء حول حقيقة أنه ربما يكون واحدًا
أو اثنين خاصةً زعيم المملكة
العربية السعودية لديه  لم يتم ذلك لأنه ربما يكون
لديه جدول زمني كامل ، وربما
كان هذا أمرًا سريعًا ،
ربما تم
الترتيب له في وقت متأخر جدًا ، لذا
لن أفعل ما كنت سأفعل
الكثير من الطريقة التي قام بها أولئك الذين فعلوا  لا
تفعل ذلك